hey guys how's it going today we're
gonna be doing the what's in my mouth
challenge and these two wonderful
suspects have volunteered to put things
in my mouth so like a bee add are you
doing I'm trying on my head okay there
we go
no like put it on your head like huh
never mind you can still see if the
coins are closed there's a water here
there are paper towels here and open
it's like III practive it it's not open
all the way yet so I have a coin wall
things in front of me and Matt and I
have collected hello Matt my and myself
collected tons of things okay so we
should start with oh look at what I say
we just do a little dumb what took that
back no you're gonna help close your
point buddy coach looks right by just go
like that yeah
what would you tongue out you didn't do
you put your I'll get I'll collect it
sit move this shirt okay gentle oh these
are sprinkles I just bought these yeah
not very good this yeah it was true okay
I just bought them freeze here one for
one I mean these are all very like we're
gonna have to come up with something
these are great treats
oh no it's nice thanks next don't
swallow this one is it do I eat it no no
no you're not sticking come on swish it
around a little don't you it so grab
your fake tooth what the hell is it
it's possibly an edible challenge no way
oh wow you spit it out it's at the top
of my face there's a really desperate
yeah we're just finding what we can
okay never open your mouth wait wait no
no okay now I have to turn towards me
this challenge I'm scared
no it's this one's not so bad okay nice
and clean it's very pleased
oh yeah I'm scared just hoping your help
salty that's not good
sponge anybody used to punch in my mouth
what does somebody okay I can't I can't
do this any longer
you're crying yeah I know why keep one
of the blood part of his body did you
put on line now nothing too bad
and it was salty it was his one book
salt and it was his mouth oh great cool
so you might write a scrub here cheap
after that iPad write something else no
you get you're talking about what you
doing
put your toe back in your mouth and said
okay Ritchie hmm open your mouth
I was scared it's okay this one's I open
wide oh my god
so it's better than anything I could
deed that was perfect
fatty just peed all over the fourth
there's also a jello on the floor that
was great alright well now we've cleaned
up the mess ah yeah well next I don't
mean what am I now it's me to do this
anymore but just this kind of open up oh
yeah get it this is it this is a good
one this open done I know this tastes
good pop rocks yeah kinds oh my god this
is not jello
why it's not my your honor that's what
your thoughts are you supposed to eat Oh
Maddy where did you go you bought the
trash bags here
well that was good um Alex he's like
strawberry Salman Khan open up mr. my
fingers in your mouth that is all right
wash it down lady wash it down with this
nice water open Oh open wine
what hmm she said you have a bad taste
at first but this is it
so Kuwait had a bad taste who's that
bubblegum what is that gum no no the the
pop rocks because the Pops is bubble gum
okay but it's actually gummy you know
suppose a swallow it's not a gum the pop
rocks turned into gum whoops I was like
oh this weird it's not good wait oh we
didn't bring any instruction that's okay
yeah because it combined with whatever
you just gave me and it was not follow
gum yeah I did but it felt not right all
right open your mouth oh look Westmark
oh yeah I'm just like a five-time today
okay neck all right open your mouth open
your mom oh boy it's cool
strawberry okay now open your mouth fun
this is
ocelots into my mom yeah excellent okay
open up not animals all right not don't
you do not chew stick no no don't do
that
no don't I want to see show KS son don't
suck on it like a candy bar
Oh daddy yeah let me it's but more now
this is a toothpick since a coffee sir
no it's your glasses what I got a good
one you're really what really rubbing
out that mmm this is I actually know
exactly this is because I can hear the
sounds of the the ends it's the piece of
the microphone that goes in the
Sennheiser your mouth sprinkles gainer
give me that okay yep
okay I like I'm a dog like I just lacks
okay SD card oh my god why I like I
actually I don't see so I'm not alright
I one more thing okay okay you know why
cause like if you give you those
eyeballs all right let me see what else
oh boy this is fun let me get some more
things here trust me she'll just trust
me ah yeah I I want some parts oh my god
put up the dog didn't eat them he's
eating grass I was like this is weird
cuz we were sticking my teeth it's kind
of sour
yeah oh my gosh this isn't really like I
know exactly what that is this my Apple
watch is your mom I don't know it's like
I mean I could like actually I can see
it with my mouth
this is wild its water
oh yeah all right guys one more okay
open wide you know this that's the code
all the guide field yeah I felt like the
edge of the yard you I'm done with this
game oh my god this is so fun I know
everything I was at the jello have a
chance why I give you a piece of that up
no big fudge and you said it was gum and
I realized that turns to come well that
was a great time I really enjoyed myself
I did too
ah thank you guys so much for watching
let me know what today we learned
Justine really likes things been putting
her mom ok but I could feel the texture
I know I didn't know what how this was
but I should know cuz he knows like I
know so anyway that was WOW let me know
what you guys think that they should put
in my mouth next I'll see you later bye
I didn't know the dog was in my mouth so
really no it was like so you actually
didn't notice how salty you didn't know
that was it
Oh salty you really didn't and then I
thought was a sponge a decision I don't
squirm exude pee so bad my pain in your
mouth I knew all the tech products then
you can go you would peed if not you
should've peed in your mom's mouth I'm
so excited